American science journalist,
Joshua Foer,
always thought his brain
was pretty average.
But one day in 2005,
while covering the
USA National Memory Championship,
a competition designed to test
the limits of the human brain,
he's presented with an
unusual opportunity -
a former champion offers to
train him to become a mental athlete.
Over the course of the year,
Joshua learns ancient methods
like memory palaces.
This is where you associate
pieces of information
with a location in your mind
to make them unforgettable.
He also uses cutting-edge
mnemonic techniques,
which allow him to remember hundreds
of playing cards in a specific order.
Soon, Joshua's competitive instinct
takes over.
He trains in his parents' basement
for hours a day.
By 2006, he's ready to attend
the championship again,
but this time not as a journalist
but as a competitor.
Round after round,
Joshua the newcomer
gives former champions
a run for their money.
He makes it to the final.
Despite being up against
a formidable opponent,
he uses the brain training methods
he was taught...
...and wins.
How could a novice like Joshua
become a champion so quickly?
Does this mean that anybody
could become a mental athlete?
To really understand
Joshua's success,
we need to consider
the role of opportunity.
It was long thought
that richer children did better
than poorer children in school
because they were more
'naturally gifted'.
But now we know that it is times
when children aren't in school,
including the long school holidays,
when poorer children lack access
to extracurricular activities,
that often creates an attainment gap.
Nutrition and access to technology
also make a contribution,
which is partly why IQ scores
across the globe
rose an average of 30 points
in the 20th Century,
factors that have literally nothing
to do with genetics.
When it comes to differences
in outcome,
it's not nature but nurture
which has the greater impact,
and it's the same with Joshua Foer.
His expert training,
access to special techniques
his opponents hadn't yet discovered,
and a quiet place to study -
his parents' basement -
that all contributed to his success.
Though it's also worth knowing that
despite being a memory champion,
even Joshua can sometimes forget
where he put his car keys.